six one seven eight three zero forty
seven fifty let's go to our next caller
from the seven one six area code caller
from seven one six please introduce
yourself and jump right into your
question hello David this is Matt from
Buffalo New York how are you doing today
good
what's on your mind all right so I was
wondering do you think that an opt-in
tax policy available or viable in
America you mean what on you only pay
taxes if you like the plan and
participate or what do you mean yes like
similar to like you pick from a list of
plans like government health care or
roads if you have a license for example
and the ones that you don't have you
don't contribute to now they don't that
would be absolute and total chaos I
would not be in favor of something like
that okay that's fair thank you David
all right no problem I mean am I missing
something there Pat like is that there's
no way that that could work right
there's it's impossible it could work if
you decide to live in the middle of
nowhere and some rural community but one
of the examples the caller gave was that
if you don't have a license you don't
have to fund the roads through your
taxes yeah but the world doesn't work
like that because I'm I don't have a car
and I'm still ordering off of Amazon
those trucks have to get to me somehow
yeah that's just how it works yeah it
seems like one of the least tenable
ideas
that that I could imagine